M
HERE IT IS. I JUSTNUAL L
JU OUTWE ASTO THE BANKINGIS B A
CEOAT THE OF TRYING TO
REHE JANET YELIS
AT TREASURYGYOU'VETING WITH THEE
FOLK LONG
PAST MGET
BEEN THEIRCALL, BUT EE WASY
WHAT WORKS AND THEY'RE ALLTRIOTP
THE SYSTEM AND MAKE IT WORK
BETTER AND ALSO AND COMMUNITY
BENEFITED BECAUSE
CAMEOT WHAYONTEDIS IS NOT GOOD E
NKING SYSTEMECTHEN
TRUSTING ALLHE AND WE
COMMUNITY. BANKS CANTHINGS
WE CAN'T SO WE KNOW WE TRY
TO SUPPO SO THIS IS NOT
BANKS THAT HADS ULAR EVENTUALLYE
RESOLVED ONE WR , AND
I THINK THEN PEOPLE SHOULD T
A  WR
A LOT OF THESE BANKS B
REPORTED EARNINGS. I THINK
P
THE FEDERAL RESERVE MADE SOME
BA DRAMATIC IT
RESOLVE RATHER SING
THE CRISIS OVER YOU WROTE IN
LETTER. THERE WILL BE
REPERCUSSIONS FOR YEARS TO COME
AREAT'S DIFFERENT. I THINK
RE LIKE C AND, U KNOW, , OBVIOUY
WE HAVE A PROBLEM. TO CHA KNOW,
BEGGING REGULARS. JUST TAKE
A EP BREATEREDSU K Y TOAT DO
WHAT DO YT OUT? HOW DO YOU
EATHEIT EASIEROM AND REGIONA? HU
ALSO M
PROBLEMSHEALTH AND
MATURITY PORTFOLIOS OR
UNINSURETHEM. FIX TTHGHHE
ALTH WE DO NOT
WHETHERONE THING RIGHT
S MORE? TO . I DON'TRE ARE I DT
HOST TDTEM.INK I  GETTINGRTHE ER
A FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS, REMEMBER ASS OF IT
HUGE PROBLEMS AND MORTGAGEMARKES
HAT THE
UBLIC THINK
THAT THIS WILL RESOLVE. AND THEN
WE SHOULDO
WHAT WENT G OU, IN THE C IIGHTSS
COMING TO AN END?
S A SIT YOU
N BUFFETT FAMOUSLY
SAID ONLY WHEN THEIE GOES OUT,
YO L BEE
NAKED WHE THESE BANKS SWIMMING
NAKED HN PLAIN SIGHT.
T UNINSUREDTSVERYONEW
INSTRUMENT EXPOSURE. EVERYONEEAE
LYEAL DIFNC WEONCENTRATED CLIENO
SILICONALLEY BANK HEADFUL OF PED
THEY JUST LEFT $140 BILLIONR
SOMETHING. OF COURSE, OF COURSE
TWO DAYS. THAT'SOTHE
EY DTH A
ISSUES. SOT'S ONLY H
THERE  MUCH OFFSIDESY. YOU WROTA
HIS IN YOUR ANNUAL HAS THIS BANS
EVIT'S
ALMOST OVER WHM REALLYGLAD TO H.
CHANCES OF A RECESON HERE.
YES. LATS
DEFINITIVE. IT'S JUST LIKE
ANOTHER WEIGHT ON THE SCALE.AY E
ATL
WON'T NECESSARILY FORCE
UMS
EA, YOU SAY MAYOMONOMY MENTIONE
SIEAR TWOVE NOTT HISTORY
KIND THAT. IT'S
N THAT THAT WE'RE
GOINOR. WE DON'T
W TA Q T,
TING E AND FOR 5 YEARS,
TIGHTENIOTE, QUANTITATIVE
CAN'T JUST
SK BECAUSE YOU
TH, JUDGME
GEA ABOUT, YOUNG
E WHATEVER HE
GO COUPLE OF YEARS.
YEARS LAT 1940 THATACK ALL THRO.
INCLUDES 1930 1940, SOALTH OF AI
STRE OF I HUMAN
CATABRAIN PER
CAPABILITY IS CAPITAL MARKETS.
WE HAVE THE WIDESTAS MOST
TRANSPARENT CAP M
MEDE'VE GOTPENN, AINCLUDES VENE
MEDIA FREEDOM OF SP,
EN RIO
PEOPO ANT.
LIKE YOU'RE STTI TO BE SO
THERE'S TWO WONDERFUL LS
US IT'S
TH IS, THAT'SHE AT THE
STILL THERE THAT HAS NOT GONE
APPLAUD IT.
MEAN, WE SHOULDING. I WROTE IN
MY LETTER
WE DO TOELP SOYMMUNITIES AHIND
D  SAID LET'S MY SHLD
A RED BLOODED AND FREEREEIS WE
SH AOR ENTERIS.
XNEGATISOSHE HILLS
DENIGRATENG, EJUST SCREWUP AND
DETS M WE'RE GOING TO KEICS
DW YEA. MY HEART IS
POLITID A LOTUR COUNTRY
SIE EAS THE CASE
JOB LIFTING UP. A OF R
Y MENTIONED
EDUCATION AND WORT.  WE HAVE
BE MOREAT ENTERPRISE IS A
WONDER, YOU
REGULATED HION
PEOPLES OUTPOGOT TODUN
PUBLIC. S AT THE
ECONOMY. WHAT DOES THAT MEAN? AS
REPUBLIC.
DIAMOND RIGHT NOW? HIS HARDER
BRAIN. BMY H MY BRAIN PART IS
SAYING THAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
GOING TO SPEND SHOUL WISELY. IT.
HOMA WHAT
GH BEING GREENODIT
WHICH WOULD BE GREEN BECAUSELD N
RATIALBOUT SST,COMPLETEL
THINK THPUROBABLY, AND I
REPUIC N BIT BETTER BIT BETTER.E
PUBLIC
. HE AND FCRHARGESS D TRP
THAT TO HANY ADVERSE IMPACT ONE
ECONOMY? ALL THIS TURMOIL? NO YO
LION AMERICANS. MILLIONTO WORK Y
KIDS AND THINGS LII THAT'S GOINT
BUNT I. ECONDP
TRUMP TERM WOULD BEE TESTION WH'
ABOUT THE MAN. IT'S ABOUT
WHETHICIES WOULD BE
AT POLICIES O ARE LOOK
POLICIES THAT HE THAAYNDHEUALLYH
TRILLION DOLLARS BACK TO AMERIC
. THE BLACK COMMUNITY HAD T